[Music]
hey everybody its charlie they released
the first official synopsis for Avengers
4 so naturally we have to break it down
it teases some really big concepts but
like infinity war you sort of have to
read between the lines like they try to
tell you as much as they can without
saying anything but the good thing now
is that the writers of infinity war have
been doing more in-depth interviews
clarifying certain story beats like
Thanos charred arm and the melted
gauntlet how that'll carry into Avengers
4 so before we get deeper into it I'll
say spoiler warning for infinity war if
you have not seen the movie yet there is
a new round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway going on all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video the supposedly
official synopsis reads a culmination of
22 interconnected films the fourth
installment of The Avengers saga will
draw audiences to witness the turning
point of this epic journey our beloved
heroes will truly understand how fragile
this reality is in the sacrifices that
must be made to uphold it two really
easy bombshells to take away from that
sacrifices being made big sacrifices to
uphold a fragile reality now for those
of you wondering how danos changed
things when everyone turned to ash based
on the reactions of war machine and
everyone sitting here in Wakanda it
seems like they remember those
characters after they were turned to ash
so I don't think that when Thanos was
erasing half of all life he also used
the mind gem to erase their memories
from existence as if they'd never been
born
he was just straight-up killing off half
the population so the other half that
survived is standing there wondering
what the hell just happened
the writers teased that Avengers 4 is
gonna have an even bigger grander story
than infinity war if you can believe
that infinity war already felt like the
biggest movie of all time
but in specifically including the term
fragile realities in the description I
think that we'll get into more
multiverse stuff without going
full-blown Secret Wars if you never read
time runs out it was the story that led
up into all realities collapsing into
one amalgam reality so that all that
existed was this one battle world there
was this Frankenstein creation of dr.
Doom's that contain fragments from a
bunch of different realities there was
an interview the Russos did before
Infinity Ward hit theaters where they
said that
the deal with Fox goes through and they
get access to the x-men characters
Secret Wars would be a really awesome
future Avengers crossover to do after
Avengers 3 and for Marvel Studios we'll
begin a new phase in its universe do you
feel like you as directors of some of
the biggest movies of the studio have
reached the end of a cycle - I mean look
we love working with Marvel we love it
yeah we didn't we prioritize the quality
of our experience with the quality of
the work and and Marvel it's always been
both areas have been of the highest you
could possibly want to desire so we've
had an amazing experience working with
them you know we've been so focused on
these movies though that we haven't been
thinking beyond them we'll say though
that that Fox deal goes through with
Disney there's a lot a lot more
characters to work with us and be
interesting to do something like Secret
Wars or so I don't think they would have
cited that as an example if they
themselves were adapting that storyline
for Avengers 4 there been a lot of
people asking about these mystery behind
the scenes pictures I'm sure it's gonna
keep happening for the rest of the year
hey what's going on with this this has
been confirmed as Iron Man using the be
AR effing technology from Civil War to
look back into the past during the
events of the original Avengers movie
which is why Captain America is wearing
his old Avengers costume but you also
see ant-man standing next to them here
there's also another picture where we
see Thor with his long blond hair his
old Avengers costume
Loki with a special muzzle on him right
before they took him back to Asgard you
look over here Iron Man's wearing a
shield jacket these are new scenes but
it also looks like more of the be ar
effing technology and Iron Man just
looking for clues in the past but just
because these scenes are them using
technology to look back into the past
using memories in not physical
time-travel that doesn't mean that there
won't be any actual time travel during
the movie because we also heard about a
casting notice for a teenage version of
Cassie Lang meaning that ant-man's
daughter at some point during the movie
will either appear from an alternate
reality or some point in the future
being much much older this is what the
actress looks like during the ant-man in
the wasp movie and the movie picks up
between the events of Civil War in the
infinity war the idea that they are post
credits
is gonna have something to do with the
snap sure which will lead right into
Avengers 4 so that gives you a sense for
the timeline in ant-man the wasp but his
daughter wouldn't get that much older
she still be a little girl
unless Iron Man's technology for using
memories to look at past events also
allows you to look at future potential
events I don't think there's any other
way to explain how she appears but
getting to the Thanos of it all they
can't do any kind of time-traveling
without getting the time stone back so
for those of you asking what happened to
him after he used the gauntlet and came
back from the soul world
Donald was all charred his arm looked
all messed up the way the riders
explained it is is that Thanos paid a
heavy physical toll for wielding that
much power at the same time so there was
a price to be paid an emotional price
because he had to give up gomorrah to
get the soul gem but also a physical
price like think about how strong Danice
was how quickly he dispatched the Hulk
at the beginning of the film like it was
no big deal
so knowing how strong the Hulk is think
about how much power that owes had to be
wielding for it to mess him up that
badly they say that he's maybe
permanently lost the use of that left
arm
remember the gauntlet is worn on his
left hand so the entire left side of his
body it just totally messed up they'll
have to address that during Avengers 4
but I think part of the reason for doing
that is they wanted to let you know that
Thanos wouldn't be able to do that again
right away like he couldn't just snap
his fingers right after that and bring
everything back immediately this is
where we get into the sacrifice
sacrifices must be made to uphold this
fragile reality there's all kinds of
theories about which characters might
die I know you know people are reaching
the end of their contracts people
wondering how Ironman is gonna
transition into the next phase of movies
is he's gonna be more of a background
character if they will kill him off and
it'll be like the comics where Tony
Stark's body starts to die so he
transfers his consciousness to a digital
realm so that he could just pop up and
be a version of Jarvis but you have to
remember that there was a big arc that
they didn't address that much during
infinity war and it was the Captain
America Iron Man art remember it was
actually banner that had to call Steve
Rogers to go track down vision and
Scarlet Witch because iron man is like I
just I can't do it we're not talking so
obviously they're gonna pay that off
during Avengers 4 but the whole idea
being that you have to sacrifice
something that you love to wield the
soul gem so you can't wield all the
Infinity stones
to fix everything and bring everyone
back without offering something that you
love the hole in that being that there
are many things that Iron Man loves that
are probably higher on the list than
Steve Rogers like he loves Pepper Potts
he loves Rhodey he loves his armor he
loves himself they implied that it
actually has to be a physical person
that you have to sacrifice though so
people like would he sacrifice his arc
reactor not unless his arc reactor
suddenly came to life but the whole idea
that conversation that he had with
Pepper Potts was that you should have
shirts in your closet not suits of armor
so they're implying that no matter what
happens he survives he dies by the end
of the movie he's hanging up that armor
the writers have given away a whole
bunch of other details and the
interviews they've been doing lately so
I'll do videos for that stuff soon but a
lot of you been asking about the fake
Infinity Gauntlet that Odin had back
during the first Thor movie and then
during Ragnarok and how he got that if
Thanos didn't go to the dwarves to get
his gauntlet till more recently so
that's probably what my next Marvel
video will be but leave all your
requests in the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Lindsey emplyees private message
me so I can get your contact details
click here to learn about all the
Deadpool 2 deleted scenes and banned
jokes in the extended cut click here for
my new spider-man 2 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]